pictures that we saw of family members
arriving at balmoral really said it all
this is a family
in mourning now and um of course
the queen was a mother a grandmother and
a great grandmother i think it is quite
telling that prince harry traveled solo
to balmoral he took we understand a
flight on his own he was not accompanied
by the duchess of sussex i think that is
deeply significant that megan was not
invited to join the family by the
queen's bedside the duke of cambridge
flew to aberdeen as quickly as he could
leaving kate behind of course this was
um prince george princess charlotte and
prince louise first day at school so she
made the very difficult decision to stay
behind to be there to collect the
children we know that this is a rift
between the royal brothers that runs
deep we know it is a rift that's caused
the queen a great deal of pain
and the brothers will be together at
belmoral this is the first time they
have been together and really since the
duke of edinburgh's funeral nearly 18
months ago and i suppose everyone will
be will be hoping that there can be some
sort of a reconciliation it's just a
tragedy that it comes across the queen's
deathbed but i do think this is a family
who will now be united in grief harry is
in balmoral i think the decision was
made for megan not to be there probably
to make this very difficult and what
will be a highly emotional family
reunion possibly easier for the rest of
the family i think inevitably there is
going to be speculation about whether or
not this
tragic passing of the queen a very
sudden passing of the queen and given
that only a couple of days ago she was
meeting her new prime minister i think
there is every hope that that this
will hopefully trigger some sort of
reconciliation between these two
brothers who for the past 18 months have
really been brothers at war